شباب هيا هياها شاحنه مدنيه تقل قوه
اسرائيليه خاصه تسللت الى مدينه جنينه
ومخيمها ايذانا ببدء عمليه عسكريه جديده
عشرات الاليات المدرعه اقتحمت المدينه من
محاور عده وحصلت منزلا في المخيم
واتت اشتباكات المسلحه الى استشهاد مدنيين
ومقاومين ابرزهم الاسير المحرر عبد الفتاح
خروشير احد قياده حركه حماس المتهم من
الاحتلال بتنفيذ هجوم حوار المسلح اواخر
الشهر الماضي كما اصيب اثنان من جنود
الاحتلال واسقطت مسيرتان خلال العمليه
التي باركها رئيس حكومه الاحتلال
لقمانها
جنودنا شجعان عملوا بشكل دقيق في قلب وكر
القتله اشيد بهم واتمنى الشفاء للجرحى بين
قوتنا اعودوا واكرر مره تلو الاخرى من يمس
بنا سيقتل
صرخات الغضب الشعبي ضد ممارسات الاحتلال
صدحت خلال الطوافي بجثامين الشهداء داخل
المخيم
مشاهد تتجدد يوميا
فوق العقل وادانت الرئاسه الفلسطينيه
ومواصفته بالحرب الشامله في حق
الفلسطينيين وطالبت المجتمع الدوليه
بوقفها فورا يكون الفلسطينيون ان استمرار
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ومستوطنيه في ارتكاب
مجازر بحقهم يؤكد ان جدوى من تفاهمات قمه
العقبه الاخيره ويرون ان ما جرى من اقتحام
وقتل واعتقاد في مخيم جنين يدمر كل سع ي
للتهدئه وفي الشارع الفلسطيني تسود حاله
غليان للرد على الاعتداء سمير ابو شماله
الجزيره من مخيم جنين فلسطين